eux aussi goûtent aux joies de la
création artistique ses enfants et
adolescents au vie chaotique placés par
la justice depuis 60 ans ils sont
accueillis dans un village dédié amboise
et ils sont devenus le temps d'un
tournage acteurs d'un court métrage âgés
de 9 à 17 ans il concourt face aux
autres villages d'enfants de francs soit
il ce reportage de samuel colin c'est
l'histoire de louise elle s'endort en
cours et se réveille sur un plateau de
tournage pour l'incarner maïs 13 ans bah
en fait ch en classe je je rêvais et du
coup à mon rêve est devenir réalisatrice
ils sont neuf du village d'enfants et
d'adolescents d'amboise devant la caméra
et une quinzaine en tout à participer
aux courts métrages
moi j'aime bien ça me permet de
découvrir
à plein de métiers parlé entre vous et
après d'action va commencer un rêve
éveillé où chaque enfant joue le rôle
d'un technicien avec derrière évidemment
une vraie équipe de tournage c'est un
travelling donc qui passe du couloir et
qui arrivent jusque dans la pièce pour
placer un peu le décor et qu'on se rende
compte que c'est un plateau c'est un
ingé son père showman script maquilleuse
ils sont seize d'une école de cinéma
parisienne il travaille sur ce projet
depuis mi-décembre à côté de leurs cours
c'est les étudiants qui a écrit le
scénario il prépare en amont alors en
lien avec les éducateurs et le village
pour organiser les repérages le casting
les répétitions et c'est un projet
pédagogique avec une ultime récompense
pour les enfants se déplaçait à paris
pour une soirée au grand rex et se voir
sur grand écran